today's eco fiend Council was the first
hosted by the European Union's Italian
presidency the focus of the Italian
economic policy work program is based on
structural reforms and investments in
growth and jobs the strategy that
Italian president suggests to addressing
girls and jobs rests on three pillars
first of all we need better market
integration and this is consistent with
the year of 2020 strategy that is to be
reviewed by the end of this year second
structural reforms as a major powerful
driver of growth in all countries and
third finance instruments to support and
boost investment both public and private
financial services and completing the
banking Union structure are also
priorities for the Italian program at
today's meeting ministers have adopted
an amendment to the EU tax rules closing
the tax loophole for corporate groups
they've also issued recommendations on
economic employment and fiscal policies
planned by the Member States this
concludes the current European semester
an annual policy monitoring process
after the European councils endorsement
of the recommendations in June the
European Commission reported progress on
the negotiations with Switzerland
Liechtenstein and Dora Monaco and San
Marino on upgrading their savings
taxations agreements with the EU the aim
is to bring their Accords up to date in
line with new products and developments
in investment behavior
you